pour accueillir les passions blessés de
la route sur karpap on a des différents
services moi je travaille en service
médullaire donc c'est les personnes qui
se retrouvent paralysées des jambes ou
également des jambes et des bras la
blessure médullaire comme on l'entend on
a à peu près 85% de blessés médullaire
issus des accidents de la route le reste
c'est les accidents de la vie sport ou
autre et il y a aussi le service neuro
central qui accueille des patients
blessés mais qui ont eu un traumatisme
crânien grave donc avec une phase
d'éveil de coma
qui est assez longue également mais ces
deux services ne sont pas ensemble c'est
des spécificités propres
un accident qui concerne une personne
englobe également la famille les enfants
quand il y en a le conjoint il est très
très important d'inclure dans la prise
en charge du patient la charge
émotionnelle qui est subie par les
familles les accompagner les leur
permettre de se reconstruire ensemble
nous on n'est qu'un passage finalement
et au final la vie la vraie vie c'est
celle qu'on a avec sa famille et même
ses collègues le travail est un milieu
aussi qui est souvent pénalisé et voilà
là-dessus on est sur un accompagnement
pluridisciplinaire et bien sûr qu'il
faut que les fameuses soient
complètement impliqués
sur la route faut faire attention
vraiment être vigilant à chaque instant
pour moi une voiture c'est un objet très
dangereux qui est dangereux pour
soi-même mais beaucoup pour les autres
on ne peut pas se permettre d'être
totalement
inconscient prendre l'alcool de l'alcool
avant de conduire ou même des substances
illicites moi je suis choquée ça m'a
modifié aussi dans mon comportement
personnel c'est à dire que moi-même si
je bois un verre je conduis pas du tout
c'est strictement proscrit je veux me
protéger je veux me protéger ce que
j'aime et les autres surtout les autres